Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai une question qui est
souvent adressée par plusieurs personnes
et donc je vais essayer
d'y répondre un peu aujourd'hui.
C'est « À quand
la véritable réconciliation? »
La véritable réconciliation,
il faudrait premièrement décider
quels sont vraiment
les signes d'une réconciliation.
Est-ce que c'est le fait d'avoir accès
à sa langue de la même manière que
le français et l'anglais sont accessibles?
Est-ce que ça veut dire des services
de santé qui sont culturellement
sécuritaires? Est-ce que ça veut dire
de se sentir en sécurité justement quand on va
adresser nos problématiques à des agents de police?
Est-ce que ça veut dire
une présence vraiment représentative
au niveau des États avec
des représentants autochtones
qui ne sont pas nécessairement
du gouvernement provincial, fédéral
ou municipal, mais qui sont là
pour les questions autochtones?
La réconciliation, c'est dans le fond
de réparer ce qui a été endommagé depuis 500 ans.
Il ne faut pas oublier que le Canada
a été bâti sur une relation
dite d'ententes et et de traités avec les
Premières Nations, mais tout ce qui a été
fait après n'a pas tendu à prouver que
justement cette entente et ce respect
étaient instaurés. Les pensionnats et
la rafle des années 60 ont juste rajouté
une couche de blessures sur toute cette
injustice qui avait été mise en place.
La véritable réconciliation, elle va être longue
à atteindre, parce que ça va demander
beaucoup d'argent, de temps, d'éducation.
De patience, aussi, parce qu'on parle
de nations qui ont été blessées
les unes envers les autres, pour pouvoir
atteindre un équilibre qui fait
que finalement, les Premières Nations
ont le droit et ont
le même niveau de respect
que n'importe quel autre
citoyen canadien ou québécois.
Cependant, avec des droits qui sont
différents, puisque nous étions ici
depuis plus de 7000 ans.
On a des droits qui sont reconnus
à l'international, même, comme étant
les premiers peuples fondateurs du pays.
Ça risque de demander énormément,
mais ce qui est vraiment rassurant,
c'est que je vois un désir d'atteindre
cette réconciliation. Je vois aussi une
progression par rapport aux relations
que les gens ont avec les Premières Nations
qui sont très différentes de celles que je voyais
quand j'avais 10 ou 12 ans, par exemple.
À quand la réconciliation?
Ça va être l'énergie
et le temps qu'on va y mettre.
Et plus on en met, plus ça va arriver rapidement.
Je pense qu'on est
beaucoup plus proche
de l'atteindre que de s'en éloigner.
Donc merci beaucoup quand vous
nous posez cette question là,
c'est que vous avez à coeur justement
cette réconciliation et ça veut dire
que le travail qu'on fait ici à Espaces autochtones
n'est pas perdu et tend
vers cette réconciliation.
Alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine et j'espère
que vous n'hésiterez pas partager le vidéo
et à nous envoyer
des questions.